[Aplausos]
para todos
es titular el movimiento rectilíneo
uniformemente acelerado
podemos pasar la diapositiva por favor
como sus islas indica el ml uva y hace
referencia a un cuerpo que se desplaza
en línea recta con aceleración constante
entonces dado que la aceleración es
constante
y yo creo que si usted siguió
estancándose temas y perdidos de pronto
no es tan conveniente porque
pues mire esas caras ya para aburrir a
todos
yo casi que estoy convencido que en este
planeta deben existir formas mucho más
interesantes últimas buenas ondas más
parchadas para hablar del mrc
o para hablar de la ciencia en general
pero cuál es el problema que si nosotros
no somos capaces de encontrar esas
formas y tampoco de inventarnos las pues
ahí es donde la situación se vuelve
grave señoras y señores jóvenes y
jóvenes
la ciencia está en crisis
perdimos la confianza que el paso
la situación es la siguiente
la forma de comunicar la ciencia es
arcaica espera unos pocos
yo a cientos de años utilizando el mismo
formato para comunicar la ciencia el
artículo científico que sólo leen los
científicos y qué pasa con el resto de
la gente no se entera
la forma comunica la ciencia no ha
innovado no se ha transformado y los
medios tampoco están haciendo la tarea
porque si ustedes se pueden a pensar
pues todavía encontramos métodos y
formas que al final se alejan mucho de
los intereses de las personas de
nosotros y esto al final lo que está
haciendo es alejar a la sociedad de
poder tener ese ejercicio del
pensamiento crítico y esto porque ocurre
pues una de las razones es los nuevos
medios masivos de comunicación ellos
abrieron el mercado de la información
nos abrirá la puerta y eso está muy bien
porque porque podemos tener ese acceso
que antes no teníamos el rollo estaba en
que estos mercados pues simplemente no
distinguen entre lo que es verdad y lo
que es mentira lo que es un hecho y lo
que es una opinión y mucho peor lo que
es conocimiento y lo que es
desinformación
entonces si nos ponemos a pensar
nosotros perdimos el control de lo que
es mira
de lo que es real y eso es real es lo
que por siglos y siglos se ha construido
a través de la experimentación a través
de la prueba y del error
cómo combatimos esto
pues un primer paso sería una ciencia
que es una forma pública la ciencia que
nos haga reír
que nos abra en un lenguaje cercano y
fresco
que de pronto alguna parodia los efectos
del alcohol pero luego expliqué la
fisiología detrás
una ciencia que nos muestre la ciencia
la cosa de las cosas del día a día de la
ciencia a lo coyuntural
porque nos muestra que la ciencia está
en todo
como nos explique uno porque se pica la
boca cuando come allí con las empanadas
o que nos cuenta la importancia
biológica y climatológica de la selva
amazónica pero que luego explique por
qué la deforestación y los incendios que
ya ocurre en sí son culpa de los seres
humanos si sería una ciencia entretenida
pero rigurosa una ciencia que nos ponga
a reflexionar una ciencia que nos ponga
a pensar a cuestionarnos a ser
conscientes de lo que nosotros podemos
fallar
en los centros que podemos tener
sería una ciencia humilde claro que
reconozca sus errores porque la ciencia
se puede equivocar
sería esa ciencia que cogiera todos
estos formatos tan populares que están
pegando ya la gente
y que están llegando a nuestros sentidos
la sentiríamos
muy de cerca por unos shows de ciencia
en vivo y telesp de música teatro
audiovisuales la podríamos cantar con
canciones de ciencia con un buen rap
conciencia
la podríamos leer con buenas historias
de ciencia
historias para todo el mundo cáritas los
rigurosas y basadas en evidencia
nos llegaría por los oídos con el
podcast
no llegaría por los ojos con vídeos
imágenes infografías o como los gases de
la cebolla nos hacen llorar
cuando ustedes corte una cebolla no sólo
están cortando sus capas este cuchillo
está haciendo una verdadera masacre
celular
cuando liberamos esas células las
rompemos pues claro sustancias se
mezclan y empiezan a subir por todos
nuestros gases hasta nuestros ojos y el
hablar de ojos esos gases llegan ahí se
mezclan con el líquido lubricante que
recubre nosotros queridos ojos y ahí se
disuelven pero en pequeñas cantidades de
ácido sulfúrico que le va a pensar y eso
lo que nos irrita los ojos ay sí claro
uno verá si llora o no el caso es que
sería una ciencia que se pudiera
aprovechar de estas narrativas como las
de youtube por ejemplo narrativas como
las de redes sociales
narrativas poderosas que pueden hablar
de cualquier cosa pero funciona muy bien
porque les llegan a los sentimientos de
las sensaciones de la gente
sería como tomarse un buen sol
residencia de ciencia clásica
un sol que no produzca collado nosotros
nos arriesgamos a eso a contarlas y es
una forma distinta que aprovecha
justamente esos recursos
y haga la ciencia atractiva
pero
ustedes dirán muy chévere este cuento de
contar la ciencia de una manera distinta
todo bien
sí
pero la tarea no está completa ahí
por eso les vamos a proponer este
ejercicio
que viajemos en el tiempo
[Música]
alguna vez alguien decidió preguntarse
por qué el sol
y ustedes que creen que las personas
alrededor de alguien me eligieron nunca
pero claramente que el único lo que es
propósito preguntarse sobre algo que es
tan seguro es que el sol se mueve por
qué pues porque si porque ayer se movió
porque antes de ayer también se movió
pero esas personas como sabían que el
sol iba a salir mañana
que ellos aseguraban es bueno pues si no
hubiera sido por ese alguien claramente
muchas personas que vienen en fila
aristarco de samos nosotros quizás
estaríamos viviendo en una época en que
no entenderíamos que es el planeta los
planetas de este sistema los que se
mueven alrededor del sol
y luego en otra época otro pelado se
preguntó
se preguntó como
aunque las cosas se cae quién sabe los
amigos
se burlaron de él por la aparente
obviedad de la pregunta para ellos era
evidente que las cosas se caen y la
razón por sí solo como dicen la costa
por caja
pero ninguna pregunta es obvia y de
hecho gracias a esta pregunta fue que
podemos demostrar que existe una fuerza
universal llamada gravedad curiosidad
curiosidad señoras y señores preguntas
ciencia buscar respuestas a esas
preguntas que desafortunadamente han
tenido las respuestas clásicas porque sí
porque porque así es un simple porque
dios la tierra
pero sobre todo las ciencias la
capacidad de buscar respuestas a esas
preguntas en la naturaleza misma de
leerla de entenderla de experimentar
experimentar
y yo creo seguramente que las ciencias
quizá unos esfuerzos colectivos humanos
más trascendentales y más poderosos si
los conocimientos que la ciencia nos ha
permitido tener a lo largo de esta
historia y en repetidas ocasiones
créanme cuando les digo por favor
han transformado drásticamente a nuestra
sociedad de muchas maneras
por ejemplo nos dieron una electricidad
nos dieron la luz la informática
nos permitieron desarrollar vacunas como
la vacuna contra la viruela
y algo muy común en estos días los
antibióticos
nos mostró que hay cientos de miles de
galaxias a millones de años luz que hay
partículas subatómicas
hay agujeros negros mundos lejanos y
mundos similares al nuestro seis
supernovas estrellas de neutrones y
radioactividad y esto solo por mencionar
algunos pocos
pero qué pasó no entiendo por qué no
estamos bien todas estas cosas
pero resulta que por más que nosotros
contemos la ciencia una forma divertida
charla directa y chévere si nosotros si
ustedes no despiertan esa curiosidad
dormida que tienen ahí entre sus cabezas
no entenderíamos y no veríamos las miles
de cosas que están pasando a su
alrededor todo el tiempo
piense en esto por un momento
desde el instante en que ustedes hombres
porque aquí nosotros dejamos de
preguntarnos de ser curiosos y curiosos
de olvidar y obviar esas preguntas
diarias como porque uno llora cuando
corte una cebolla ya esto agréguele
estas formas a veces muy inconvenientes
de contar la ciencia desde ese instante
entre todos todos estamos pagando este
precio y además estamos haciendo algo
más abrimos
la puerta abrimos la puerta al tierra
plans
a negacionistas del cambio climático
como algunos presidentes por ahí
y entonces
qué va a pasar
se están demorando se están afectando la
implementación de medidas que
necesitamos para vivir en una crisis
climática de adaptación y de mitigación
estamos en el mundo hay personas que no
creen que hayamos llegado a la luna de
antigua cunas que según la o ms es una
de las diez principales amenazas para la
salud en el mundo
estamos viendo es eficiencia y
desinformación
y para esto hay que el renacer quitamos
un segundo renacimiento volver a
conectarnos con el conocimiento
volver a preguntarse a cuestionarnos
volver a ver la vida con los curiosos
conoces que estén pendientes de los
detalles
llenos de preguntas de si alguna vez
ustedes se encuentran en una cadena de
what's up que se encuentra en internet
que el limón y el bicarbonato funcionan
para curar el cáncer
y por favor piensen los dos peces
cuestiones preguntaría a alguien más que
sepa de estos temas corroboren con otra
información esto es muy importante
seamos lo suficiente escépticos
vayamos más allá cuestionemos todo
porque él les va esa es la sociedad que
nosotros soñamos y ese es el cambio que
queremos lograr
sin su curiosidad ojo sin su curiosidad
por más que inventemos miles de formas
para hacer la ciencia más divertida
charla del iter quiebre jamás tendremos
un impacto significativo
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]